Melinda: I'm Melinda Gates, I'm co-chair of
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
What I would like to say to Anita and so many
other girls around the world is that many
of us are working on your behalf and we realize
it takes a lot of things to change society
for girls.
Whether that's laws around education policies,
laws around child protection, laws around
property right.
And changing programs to think about how we
reach girls because a lot of times you're
not reaching the education system.
And I think that if we change the programs
so that we reach you in other places out in
your village, you can lift yourselves up economically
and make your way into college and onto school
and a better life.
And so we applaud Anita and all she has already
done and those that she also encourages in
this struggle.